going ahead with our urine review this
is interesting there are a lot of times
that people involved with this show
butchered the English language
remember when Sal tried to pronounce
abominable oh yeah
you mean you you vote doesn't look like
it's an abdominal prevalence please
Obama Obama double abominable snowman
back you Larry's abominable calories a
barnable a bonbon justice statistician
abdominals snow so there was a lot of
butchering of English language and
thread uses these drops all the time but
some of the mispronunciations are so up
you know they're not they're not that
obvious so we made a game out of it
Robin there's no one else you can play
the game I'll play with you see if you
can remember which words were pronounced
incorrectly last year all right Bobo did
Bobo butcher the word equation or
symbolizes equation or symbolizes Bobo
I'm gonna say symbolizes all right let's
lock in on symbolizes Robin you are
right
here's Bobo now the Hat symbolizes it
exactly that's why wait a second Craig
what does he say stem alliance
symbolizes yeah he symbolizes it yeah I
pay tribute to Maya
Emeline symbolize hello similes sy and
bol ISE all right close enough to and
you didn't get it right but how do you
say similes where's the beam them alive
similes
say it again and recognize what you just
said similes say it slowly them Oh oh my
god where's the B takes to be out Sam oh
wise use the B no that's as far as we
got sorry good Robin so far your 1 for 1
silent B all right let's stick with Bobo
this year in 2019 did Bobo butcher bar
mitzvah or cognitive I know not easy
Bar Mitzvah or cognitive cognitive
you're right
cognitive here we go I'm gonna be honest
Ralph and I've talked on a Bluetooth in
my sound system which I tell my students
just do impaired you're not conscious
conjugate inattention blindness Robin
conjugate conjugate that's right when I
Drive over a bridge I'm not conscious of
my surroundings Jesus Christ
sound Hodge native what are you not
aware just around it why it's called
inattention blindness when you're a
falls in your face that's an attention
blindness it's it's cognitive he must
have read the word and then [ __ ] it up
alright lebra B you're doing pretty good
on this game alright let's go back to
Ronnie did Ronnie butcher the word in
2019 systemic or concierge and believe
me maybe he just kind of maybe dr. Cohn
Sierra and the concierge teaching you
well there you go
confit air you gotta say it now cuts
yeah that's yeah you mean you didn't
learn after that no why would I bother
learning
concierge a safe for real thank for real
come on see ya
[Music]
fancy air ah yeah fancy air concierge
alight each I bother teaching you or you
know good concierge concierge country
air concierge your even concierge
concierge concierge hey you got it I
know it's like Ronnie
kunti hair said it whatever dude I find
a guy's desk I know where to go why have
I do all right Robin you're doing well
I'm gonna give you one more to wrap up
2019 pronunciation game did Sal you're
good with Sal did Sal butcher the word
dabbling for the word massage I'm gonna
say gambling you got one wrong massage
did he see some like massage or
something here here's the club you don't
want cameras in the room no but the cops
know you know you want TVs in the room
with cameras outside of the room why
well if you're having a nice massage and
there's a monitor in the massage room
how do you how do you say it massage
monitor it's like massage if this was a
vision if they had had a brain it was
one time Howard a guy went for a massage
massage there he goes it's a soft G
massage which I listen me yep massage
massage all I got Sh yeah yeah yeah that
sounds odd dude
you spent half your life in massage
parlors what's going on with everybody
this is a guy who goes to massage
parlors all the time and he was a
science app about it too yeah
yeah he made a massager yeah massage so
guys would no way to get a broadband